ever wondered what it's like to be an
erasmus student in Europe's capital of
cool Berlin Erasmus has been so
successful since it started in 1987 that
it has been the inspiration for Erasmus
bus
hi mrs. Roberts he's an exchange student
from the UK studying chemistry at Hamad
University and today he's our guide
erasmus+ is the European Union's new
integrated program for education
training youth and sport for 2014 to
2020 it will provide more opportunities
for studying and working across Europe
and even beyond Europe than ever before
heading inside from Germany it's really
nice sweet you guys I'm going to Maine
booyah let's go okay
erasmus+ offers all sorts of exciting
new initiatives including partnerships
between education providers and
companies to help people find work not
just for students but also for school
pupils volunteers apprentices adults and
teachers - wow I'm so impressed you guys
are really challenging yourselves here
at University hi I'm Cecilia I'm Bacchus
nice sweet you were you from Belgium my
name is David st. come from listen work
what have you guys going on here named
Cairo skills Erasmus is all about unique
group of people you are with
we don't have enough time together but
the memories will make will last forever
every day there are magical moments such
as these we will treasure for a lifetime
Berlin is cultured Berlin is erm but
don't forget there are many more cities
where you can study train gaining work
experience and volunteer with Erasmus
plus
hi I'm Peter Pennsylvania hi I'm Nina
corporation hi
I can't go abroad since I have a
part-time job
but I can exchange with other cultures
while being in Berlin which is really
really great so is this like a normal
situation here please yeah another
fantastic night another awesome meal
talking sharing and maybe one day
working together erasmus+ were
transformed the careers and lives of
millions of people so make sure you
don't miss this once-in-a-lifetime
chance to study abroad and race other
cultures and change your perspective on
Europe
you